as you've probably figured out by now
bootstrap has a lot of really great
functionality that's going to save you a
lot of time but you probably want your
site to be a little bit more unique and
have some Styles that are really
specific to it that you can't find
within bootstrap to include your own
custom styles you're gonna need another
style sheet that has everything you want
to achieve that's not included in
bootstrap to do so add a new file to the
CSS directory or the CSS folder called
style dot CSS inside style dot CSS will
include the styles that are unique to
our page remember you're gonna want to
start working with the largest elements
and then move to smaller and more
specific elements inside style dot CSS
where should you start would you start
with the background color the margins or
padding of the page or the font styles
including the color typeface and weight